everything in human experience and
really human history or human
civilizations experience is that
everything seems to fall to the earth
that if it's if they have water
particles they don't just if they're
large enough they don't just float up
they don't if they're small enough
they're being held up by the wind and
all of that but if they're if they're
large enough if they're large enough
they will fall that you don't have
people that are able to just float
around they'll fall you don't have
taxicabs that float around they'll fall
and not only will the water fall it'll
hit the ground it'll puddle up and if
there's a gutter it'll fall into the
into the into the gutter it's just
trying to get lower and lower and lower
or if I were to drop a bunch of needles
they would just fall they don't if I
have a needle at rest here doesn't
automatically for no reason all of a
sudden jump and and and or fly upwards
or start to float and and so this is a
thing that's just fundamental to
everything that we've ever ever
experienced
and so for most of human history or
human civilization we just accepted it
as a given we thought well look that's
just obvious everything would just
everything should just fall down that's
just the way the universe is to think
otherwise would be crazy and that's why
this guy right over here is one of the
greatest geniuses of all time and he did
many more things than just the things
I'm going to describe in this video each
and in any one of those things would
have earned his place in history but
this is you could have you might already
know this is Isaac Newton Isaac Newton
easily one of the top-five minds in all
of human history so a pretty fascinating
dude and one of his big insights about
this whole thing's falling down problem
is do they have to fall down is this
just something that we should assume
about the universe that if you know if
your that things just need to fall down
and he says it that and he or at least
it were told that he did tell people
that he was somewhat inspired to come
upon this way of thinking by observing
an apple falling from a tree it's
probably not true that you'll see in
some cartoons on TV that the Apple hit
his head or or hit his head while he was
sleeping and gave him the idea but if
most people were to see let me draw a
tree here
if most so that's a twig right over
there maybe I'll draw some leaves so if
most people if most people so that is
and let me draw the Apple over here so
this is the Apple right over here so if
most in for most people if I were to
kind of snap this twig right over here
it's completely common sense the Apple
would fall and if most people were to
observe that they would just think it's
a normal happening in the universe but
for Isaac Newton at least on that day
when he observed that Apple he says well
you know why did that why did that Apple
fall and this to some degree is a great
example of out of box thinking because
something that for thousands of years or
tens of thousands of years human beings
had taken for granted just because
that's the way it always was he actually
asked the question why does it always
have to be that way and that question
took them down an entire line of
reasoning that set up the basis for all
of classical mechanics which for the
most part we still use today
they've been - it's been tweaked a good
bit by this gentleman in the last
hundred years but for most purposes when
we're engineering things or dealing with
things on the surface of the planet and
we're not done and we're not going close
to the speed of light we can still use
the mathematics that Isaac Newton came
up with from this simple question and
not only was he able to kind of think
that there's something there's something
that might be pulling somehow acting on
this Apple bringing it to the earth but
he actually formulated an entire an
entire I guess law around this thing so
as you can imagine the thing that Isaac
Newton believes brought the Apple to the
earth is gravity is gravity and he
formulated the universal law of
gravitation or the law of universal
gravitation either way and in it he he
theorizes that the force between two
objects and it's a vector quantity it's
always going to attract the two objects
to each other so the direction is
towards each other the force of gravity
between two objects is going to be equal
to the
big G which is really just a number it's
a number and we'll see in a second and
it's a very small number maybe I'll
write it there this is a small number
I'll cook I'll give you that number in a
second it's equal to this constant this
universal gravitational constant which
is a super duper small number times the
mass of the first object times the mass
of the second object divided by divided
by the distance between the two objects
the distance squared so this is distance
distance between between two between
both of those two objects so if you're
talking about the force of gravity on
earth this right over here you'd pick
one of the masses to be earth so this
mass over here if you were talking about
on earth you would pick one of them to
be earth this is the object that you're
that's on earth maybe it's me and then
this is the distance from between the
center of masses of both of those
objects so between the center of me if
you were to if you and I won't go into
the detail that'll make a more detailed
video on center of masses and the center
of the earth so it's roughly the
distance from the surface of the earth
or if I'm about five foot nine about
half of that distance of you know where
I get the distance from my bellybutton
about to the center of the earth is this
number right over here so right when you
see this before we even talk about you
know me in and earth or needles and
earth or or taxicabs and earth and that
force of gravity you might something
bizarre might be raising up in your
brain you might say wait the way the way
gravity is defined by Isaac Newton or
this this this formula that we were
given right here it's saying that we
have gravity between any two objects and
you're saying look I'm looking at I'm
looking at a computer screen right now
so you're looking at a computer screen
right now and let me draw it take my
best attempt at drawing a well this is
an old school computer not a flat-panel
but gets the job across so you're
looking at a computer screen right now
how come you aren't attracted to the
computer screen how come it doesn't fly
into your face
the answer there is is that this number
this number is really small and there
actually is there actually is some force
of attraction between you and the
computer it's just that it's more than
over over compensated for the friction
between the computer and the desk the
the friction between you and your seat
and which is frankly being caused by the
force between you and the earth the
force of gravitation the force of
gravitation between the computer and the
earth that both of you and the computer
such small masses that you you really
can't notice it you really it's really
negligible it's being overpowered by
other forces that are keeping the
computer from even drifting into your
face or your face drifting into the
computer so just to get a sense of that
this G this this this you know this big
G this constant of proportionality just
to get a sense of how small it is this
is and I'm going to round it here six
point I'll write approximately six point
six seven times times 10 to the negative
11th Newtons and we'll talk about
Newton's Newton's is the metric unit of
force Newton meters per kilogram squared
or it's actually let me write it this
way Newton Newton times now I want to
say this correctly Newton times meter
per kilogram meter per kilogram squared
so it's this way it's the strange set of
units here but the units are really
there so that when you multiply it by
two masses which are in kilograms and
divide it by a distance which is in
meters you will end up with Newtons but
I want to make it clear that this is a
super small number 10 to the negative
11th if I were to just write 10 to the
negative 11th it would be zero point
zero and then we would have one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
11 this is some see one two three four
five six seven eight nine 10 11 so this
number right here is the same thing as
six point six seven times this thing
over here so this is a super small
number and that's why when you were
multi
apply it by not so large numbers if you
don't use earth if you use you and a
computer you're going to end up with a
still a super duper duper duper small
for something that's so small you won't
notice it it's going to be overpowered
by other forces so these things don't
fly into each other but when you think
about really massive bodies like the
earth the force of gravity starts to
become noticeable very noticeable and
I'm not going to give you the mass of
Earth in this video although that's
interesting and you can look it up
yourself but if you put in the mass of
Earth right over here if you put it in
right over there and if you put in the
roughly the distance from the surface of
the earth to the center of the earth
therefore R and you multiply that times
G all of these terms right over here so
this term if you multiply that term
times that term and divided by this term
squared they simplify too they simplify
to what's sometimes called little G
little G so this right here you could
view that as the gravitational field at
the surface of Earth it's also the same
thing as the acceleration of gravity
near the surface of the earth and this
is and once again I'm just going to
round it for the sake this is the this
is this comes out to be units wise 9.8
meters per second squared and then
you're left with just the other mass so
x times m1 so for simplicity if
something is close to the surface of the
earth the distance does matter but if
we're if we're simplicity if we're close
to the surface of the earth we can say
that the that the the force of gravity
is going to be this little G thing times
whatever the mass is that is close to
earth so if you take if for example you
were to take me and I weigh let's say I
weigh 70 kilograms so in the case of Sal
Sal has a actually I shouldn't say way I
have a mass of 70 kilograms I have a
mass of 70 kilograms weight is actually
a force but we'll talk will clarify that
more later my mass is 70 kilograms then
we can figure out the force that the
earth is is pulling down on me which is
actually my weight so
this situation the force is going to be
G which is 9.8 meters per second squared
so it's 9.8 meters per second squared
times my mass which is 70 kilograms
times 70 times 70 kilograms and let's
get my handy ti-85 out to figure this
out let's so I get 9.8 9.8 x times 70
and that gives me 686 so this is equal
to 686 kilogram meters per second
squared kilogram meters per second
squared or this is the exact same thing
as this the same right over here this is
the definition of a Newton so this is
this is a Newton which is appropriately
named for the guy that that's the father
of all of classical physics so my weight
on earth which is the same thing as the
force that Earth is pulling down on me
or that or that
the gravitational attraction between me
and earth I should say is 686 686
Newtons now I will ask you an
interesting question now I will ask you
an interesting question so here is Earth
here is earth and I am not even a speck
of a speck of a speck on earth but for
the sake of simplicity let's say that
this is me I'm hanging out in the Indian
Ocean someplace so that that is me and
we already know that Earth is pulling
down on me is pulling down on me with a
force of 686 Newtons now my question to
you is am I is am i pulling on the earth
with any force and am i pulling on the
earth with a larger or a smaller force
than it is pulling on me and your gut or
just you know your knee-jerk reaction
might be well look Earth is so huge Sal
is so tiny
clearly the earth must be pulling with a
greater force on Sal than Sal is pulling
on the earth
unfortunately the that's not the case
that I am so the earth is pulling on Sal
at 680 with the force of 686 Newtons and
Sal is also pulling on the earth with
the force of 686 Newtons so Sal is also
pulling on the earth it makes me feel
very powerful with the force of 686
Newtons but you might say wait that
doesn't make sense Sal if if I have a
building over here and if you were to if
you were to let's say jump from the
building you're going to start the force
of gravity is going to be acting on you
and you're going to start accelerating
downwards it doesn't seem like the earth
is accelerating up to you wouldn't we
all notice that every time someone were
to jump off a building if the earth
started accelerating in a major way and
the way to think about that is the force
is the same and we'll touch on this in
more detail in other videos but force is
equal to mass times acceleration so when
we're talking about 686 Newtons 686
Newtons in terms of the force that earth
the gravitational attraction between
myself and earth and this is going to be
equal to 68 68 kilograms then it
provides a pretty good acceleration on
me so in this case if you solve for a if
you solve for a over here you're going
to get the 9.8 meters per second squared
now if you do the same thing for Earth I
already told you that we're pulling on
each other with the same force 686
Newtons
but now the if you want to figure out
how much is the earth accelerating from
that force you're going to get a I won't
even put it here you're going to put a
huge number in here huge number times
the acceleration of Earth towards me and
says this is such a huge number very
very very large number this is going to
be an immeasurably small number super
super small number and frankly it's
probably averaged out by the
acceleration of Earth - or the force of
gravity between Earth and all the other
people and things on the surface of the
planet so it all averages out in the end
but even if it didn't even if I was the
only thing that the earth was
interacting with it would be negligible
you wouldn't even notice the
acceleration of Earth towards me but you
wouldn't notice the acceleration of meat
or
earth because because of because of our
vastly different masses even though we
have the same even though the force of
attraction is the same